you you know how crazy when I when I
when I decided to be a factor my friend
said to me he goes he goes huh
because you want to be an actor huh yes
terrible idea I go I want to I be a
senator while you're at it cuz he goes
you really he goes no I said I want to
be a actor he goes you want to be a
movie star and I go yeah and he goes um
I guess and he goes no you don't guess
that's what you want to do and he said
so why don't you try being a senator and
I was like what do you mean he goes well
there are a hundred senators how many
movie stars are there you got a better
chance of being a Centon and I was like
I don't like that I don't like these
odds I don't put that but the odds are
stupid that I hate when people if you
ever made decisions based on of course
I'm just saying no it's just when you
have a dream you go for it but the
chances of making it it's so stupid to
me when people go you know chance you
make in Hollywood less than one I don't
need that yeah I mean I don't need any
of that but that's those aren't that is
the reality that is the numbers word
it's the reality but if that's your
passion odds do not dictate your dreams
at all it doesn't make sense of your
odds just go for lost alone listen when
people give you on yeah cuz you know a
lot of times it's you're you're in your
own way and that's that's that that kind
of talk gets in your own way you know
but but it that's crazy though it's true
but I understand it worth playing for
worth it but here's the thing so I'm not
saying don't pursue a professional
career in sports you can do that but in
the things you pick up along the way are
gonna be learning experiences you're not
gonna get in any working field in the
world yes and then the network that
people are gonna meet and the workout
they're getting get from it and then
maybe your your best friend is he's in
the NFL - and then you guys do something
after that and you both all have these
experiences in life that is not you
can't get anywhere else
and your learning must turn and [ __ ]
like that you learn a lot of stuff you
know one of the biggest problems now
with education that they're finding is
that because people are making their
specializing so much you're learning
you're not learning really like a myopic
I mean you're learning you're very
myopic you're not learning you're not be
able to apply what you're learning this
little thing this little field into a
lot of other things so range is also
important so a lot
times when you go for stuff learning
essentially you're learning a lot more
than you think you are you know you get
you gain a lot um yeah it's crazy man
but in some schools now you know they
really you remember especially when I
was the especially when you were growing
up but especially with me that remember
like remembering dates like when did
this happen there's no more of that
because I just googled the date yeah now
you learn the concept okay why so bill
worried ass but also you [ __ ] idiots
you got me learning yeah when
Christopher Columbus when the first
amendment all this [ __ ] I know I go I'm
memorizing number I know I don't even
know what I'm learning out of thing no
I've no idea what happens now what the
thing is because all wonders pass the
test at 19 whatever it is instead of
teaching me but they're doing the same
thing colleges now that she's not
anymore to think anymore now it's chance
now they don't do dates now they why was
this a bill cuz I did this get passed
right what was going on the reason which
is brilliant a lot of people come out of
it not knowing they were even talking
about in science a lot of times the
models people use for climate science
whatever it might be a lot of times
they're not even aware of how the model
came to be who came up with the model
and is that model actually working in in
the real world and so there are all
kinds of shortcomings said that are
being addressed very interesting but
also like especially with kids like
there's pros and cons of YouTube and
iPads but some of those kids they
learned [ __ ] so fast now that they're on
their iPad yeah we go to preschool and
they're teaching my son colors and
numbers he's like bits please that's
what and he'll thank you all the
alphabets all the colors like this is
what you want to do for the year well no
he knows it yeah cuz he got it off his
learning apps that we have them at home
there's no you gotta do something else
for my money here you gotta teach him
some other [ __ ] whatever this is we're
past Netflix has the show that my kids
watch an education show it's so [ __ ]
entertaining they learn everything they
learn [ __ ] they wouldn't even learn in
school it's unbelievable like yeah the
traditional ways of education is yeah
well you know that was based on it was
based on the Victoria model of creating
good factory workers
I see you have a bell you sit at a desk
you sitting in a row it's just like it's
like an assembly line so it was based on
line being good so we're not being
innovated with that was it all the
coffee being crystally this morning and
people dress like maybe I'm just I'm so
not hip the new style of people like in
tucking their shirt they're passing
their colorful socks with the shoes a
lot you don't like you don't miss
fashion it's turning a little bit too
casual for me
uh-huh I feel they weren't not you like
this is what yeah but like when people
make an attempt to dress and just in
sweats well go to might like it look at
what Chris was wearing look at these
pants here's were girls do that - no
there's for a hot minute it was like
lingerie top and then sweatpants look at
him look at them for a second look at
his pants what are you what are you
wearing then a meeting at 9:00 a.m. you
know he's very playful right now it's
tired I can't get into the sweat game
movement like that's just never will
never be my style you know I did the
other day I mean I'm wearing these but I
was like at I'm 36 years old my sneakers
all the time
so when I'm about some dope-ass more
stylish boots to wear you do have other
boots
you saw my my Gucci's yeah other boots -
don't you a lot of boots I have a lot of
boots yes but you have to go shout out
to tackle buy new ones got to buy some
some boots that's money on you're on
Rodeo Drive I know that you know you did
know that on Rodeo Drive you do know
that and yeah you have eyes everywhere
all right what Saint Laurent your ass
you sent us five st. Laurent YSL
I did get boots but I need an outfit for
my
stuff for Showtime can I see the boots
if you're gonna like him dude you're
gonna like him you can appreciate them
these with jeans and an iced tea all
right dude come on man Marty no they're
not pointy you're gonna you're gonna
prove of these these are very because I
need myself a good pair of boots but
your those are nice boots ease you use
boots well that's a great food right
that's a great boot that's a class in
there the most comfortable boot and
they're not giving them away I know that
they're not giving those away yeah I
don't know dude yeah you sound oh ho so
you sound oh ho with nice jeans - tongue
God because I can't just be wearing
sneaks all the time gray sneaks now the
shirts gonna piss you off a little bit
and I want to wait till you see on
Showtime wearing it is it gold and black
yes it is
and when I what I went man Rogan Callen
are not gonna like this I'll take it no
Chris will appreciate it yeah I'll take
it you guys is my impression of Chris
and [ __ ] Brennan all those are dope
yeah yours are dope too those are sick
as they're looking at shoes but you out
see I want to wear those sweats Chris's
where I can't get down with the sweat
movement I just can't I'd that's how I
talk behind Kristin hey how about Chris
post attention if you're fan of mine and
reside Miami do not go to this [ __ ]
actively campaigning
Miss USA she's an attorney she was pro
bono to help prisoners get like a
shorter sentences for like unjust
whatever reasons the god to prison she's
beautiful there's a bunch I have
somebody here to bet you did Chen
gorgeous yeah she's an MBA - oh yeah
walk there's a [ __ ] over and left wow
she is a [ __ ] superhero what else
yeah she got anyone where she's not in a
uniform you want a naked I just want to
see like more damn she is gorgeous
keep going
don't you think about making Superman
babies with her Brian does that have a
crush of mine yes I do
Wow hey I'm bright y'all don't worry she
might just make grunting sighs stupid we
are the regulations on your on your way
in dude she's you're also a nut lawyer
I'd I'd do my sexy voice when I talk I'm
looking that I spent some money on a
girl you like to shop or what
where's more money they want to come sit
in on part of the kid she's in LA yeah
she's from North Carolina I believe she
was a year ago she was a year ago
take it easy to make cars to me girl
yeah yeah there you go there you go
she's a lawyer yeah and an MBA and their
undergraduate ba hey dude don't talk
about my girl I cut off my right leg red
you see I got my right leg just to bring
around my friends to talk to [ __ ] yeah I
come to the comedy store like but look
at this dude
peep this that yeah your girl stupid
yeah and she's that and that bad show me
that bet hey that's aggressive show me a
brain by brain I mean titties yeah she's
yeah what else we got chin mean any
other pictures of house the booty though
I wonder if that's it I did see it it
wasn't like it didn't stick out you see
what happens nice you see what happens
she's a flat earther by Friday so I mean
flat booty that's what I call flat flat
earthers okay yup that one that's how
her [ __ ] it's only girl I know usually
if they Abu Tate did they will
definitely peep it
she has 19,000 followers you know after
this she looks like she has a bootie
Nora turns it's hard to see though her
name is Chelsea has an athletic she
athletic yeah yeah hey great great
comment Miss Teen USA love your giant
here love you and your giant
okay okay though oh well thank you I
hear a lot of girls talk to each other I
love your giant hands your hair when you
see my back I pull myself up like a
champ like 30 times fast
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gift it's a gift
it's a gift